it's it's less about a particular
organization or a particular activity
it's about whether or not you've given
the money in such a way that you can
actually have some confidence that it's
going to make the change in the world
you want and that change can be you know
having another student at risk of
dropping out actually being able to
graduate on time that change could be
getting a existing cost effective drug
for malaria to a child in time that you
save that person's life I distinguish
between high-impact philanthropy and
other types of philanthropy because some
philanthropy isn't practiced in such a
way that it can assure those kinds of
results in fact many philanthropists
don't necessarily give with the idea of
trying to maximize the social good of
their philanthropy so for those folks
who are giving out of a sense of
obligation or reciprocal giving my
buddies on a board he gave money to my
fundraiser so I gave money to his
fundraiser or you know I don't care so
much about I'm speaking from the point
of view of philanthropist I don't care
so much about whether or not I am really
maximizing the impact of my gift but I'm
really happy that my name is on that big
building so that's high-impact
philanthropy is different from that kind
of social or reciprocal philanthropy in
that it's squarely focused on improving
the lives of others all philanthropy
especially high impact philanthropy
where people are really focusing on
results it starts with a personal
commitment and so you know this is it's
a personal commitment to making a change
in the world and how people got to that
commitment is a very unique and personal
journey I don't think you want to
disrupt that journey because one of the
things with high-impact philanthropy is
you have to have a commitment to ongoing
learning there are no silver bullets so
you have
to be able to care enough about the
issue to learn when you've goofed up and
to redirect or add more resources than
you thought you needed in order to
achieve your good and what's exciting is
when a philanthropist says I'm committed
to making a change in this area whatever
that area is once you get to that point
then you say great how can you translate
that commitment and those good
intentions and whatever resources you're
bringing to the table to actually making
the difference you want to make you know
that that's where hopefully our work
plays is to to translate those good
intentions and that commitment to actual
impact
we do know there are several motivations
for why people give I mean one of the
biggest ones is simply they are asked
and so it's a reaction to a request by
somebody who either they have a personal
connection to or who's describing a knee
that somehow resonates with them other
folks give because they see themselves
as a member of a particular community
and they feel like they have a
responsibility or role in that community
as a leader and philanthropy is one way
that they demonstrate that leadership
there are others who have been motivated
because of a particular trigger event
they lost their mom to cancer and
because of that personal experience have
become committed to you know addressing
that issue and hopefully alleviating
some of the pain and suffering that they
experience in their family as a result
of the mom having cancer one thing that
was interesting from a study that we
conducted where we interviewed 33 high
net worth individual philanthropists was
how much of the information they get
around their philanthropy comes from a
pretty narrow set of information sources
right now it's the popular press the
sort of major periodicals and it's their
friends their their social network the
peer network and one of the reasons our
center was started is because you know
if you're really trying to figure out
where your dollars can do the most good
you need some pretty good information to
make a smart decision and you know right
now we talked about the million-dollar
question that the kinds of
philanthropists we're trying to help are
asking and that is I'm not the kind of
guy who wants the name on the building
this isn't about social philanthropy
this is about my trying to figure out
where I can do the most good with the
dollars I have
the top issue is right now a sense of
frustration that they're not sure
whether or not they're making a
difference and so you know what was top
on the minds of the folks that we're
talking we were talking to when we
started discussing philanthropy was how
can I have more confidence than actually
making a change and if I'm going to
continue doing this I need to know
better that my dollars are actually
improving someone's life and that's not
only findings from our study but other
studies where people have said have
asked the question what would make you
give more and it was better information
on cost and better information on impact
I don't even think in the top five or
ten it was more of a tax benefit
what we do know is that there's a lot of
there's a lot of talk surrounding a kind
of generational shift in philanthropy a
set of philanthropists who want and
expect more involvement in whatever
philanthropic activity they are engaged
in so you know the idea is that if
that's where they're starting if there
is this desire to be more than a more
than just writing the checks then I
think what the sector needs to do is
figure out how can you leverage those
good intentions and frankly a lot of
talent that could be servicing the
mission of the organization and make
sure that you know that talent that
energy doesn't go too distracting folks
from the mission of the organization or
that organizations don't somehow get
beholden to the whims of a
philanthropist that things that this is
their pet project
the problem right now is there isn't
enough good information around the
nonprofit's results in order for you to
give a meaningful ranking so ideally
with a non-profit what you want to rank
on is their ability to transform their
resources into good given the state of
the field what we have our information
on certain inputs like the amount of
money that goes into programs but inputs
is not really what high impact
philanthropists or most of these
nonprofits care about this is not about
counting the number of dollars you spend
it's about the other side of the
equation which is given the number of
dollars you spend what results did you
see I think what you look for in a
nonprofit organization is not are they
solving the root cause or putting on a
band-aid but given what they're trying
to solve are they doing that well
with philanthropy just like with any
other decision there are three things
that could happen one you could do good
you could have the results you intended
to you could throw a lot of resources
and not make a whit of difference or
three you can actually do harm to the
communities that you intended to serve
so the notion of high-impact
philanthropy is can you approach or
philanthropy in such a way that you wait
the outcome to the first which is doing
as much good as you can there's a study
that Bank of America had sponsored
Center on philanthropy in Indiana
produce the study and they looked at
what prevented people from giving more
the question may have been phrased what
would cause you to give more than you're
giving and the top two answers were
related to cost and impact when we did
our own study which was called I'm not
rockefeller because that was a that was
actually a remark we got from multiple
people some sentiment like oh you're
calling me a philanthropist that's not
really who I am despite the fact by the
way that they gave on average a million
dollars a year what we found was there's
a great deal of latent philanthropy so
what we heard in the answers to our
questions was frankly a lot of angst
about the fact that they weren't giving
as much as they knew they financially
could or as much as they wanted to so it
wasn't for a lack of good intentions in
many cases they had actually put the
money aside specifically for
philanthropy and it wasn't for lack of
financial capacity they had plenty of
money there to give it was for lack of
confidence that that money would make a
difference and at least the way they saw
the field now they couldn't figure out
how to get that confidence that they
were making good decisions without
essentially turning it into a full-time
job for folks like them who want to make
a difference and who have the financial
capacity is there a way week
get them to smarter decisions faster so
that we begin unlocking that capital and
you know that that is that is one of the
chief challenges that our Center is
trying to address by doing some of the
legwork for them doing the due diligence
going bleary-eyed reading these academic
studies that we can actually do a lot of
homework that will get them to making
the smart decision faster
one structural difference between the
nonprofit in the for-profit sector is in
the for-profit sector the payor the
person who gives the money to the
organization is also the recipient of
the good so you've got a nice little
virtuous cycle right if you had to
lemonade stands and you had and you know
for profit one let one stand has great
lemonade one stand has terrible lemonade
the consumer of the lemonade decides and
starts you know feet giving the money to
the good lemonade stand the bad lemonade
stand dies in the nonprofit sector the
whole point of their work is they are
trying to help individuals and
households and communities who don't
have the dollars to spend to help
themselves and so you don't have that
nice reinforcing loop and that's one of
the reasons why it's so difficult to
have the kind of performance management
that you would want to see the
interesting thing with microfinance
micro lending is that it's been it's got
a lot of attention because it is using a
market-based activity lending where a
return is expected in terms of interest
to a social ill which is poverty so I
think it's part of a broader trend
around looking at kind of hybrid
solutions to social issues you know it's
double bottom these are some of the
terms that get floated around around
this kind of hybrid approach to doing
good philanthropy ilysm double or triple
bottom line investing impact investing
those are all ways to think about can
you apply business / market models or
principles to doing good and I think
microfinance is one example of a way
that you can
you